- Do you remember the
first place you performed?
What was your first thing you did?
- Well, Willies my home,
Willies in Stillwater, Oklahoma.
I went to school at
Oklahoma State University
and went through graduation,
got my blank diploma, kinda thing,
and then got the call that I'm
one hour short of graduatin'.
So I had to go back up for,
and I didn't have any money, whatsoever.
So I went down to a place called Willies.
A lady named Dolly, Bill
and Dolly was there.
And Dolly says, "I'll give you a shot."
I played one night, and she
was so sweet to me, man.
It was that night she
looked at me, and she goes,
"You know I'm tryin' not to negotiate
"against myself here on price," she goes,
"but you're kinda good at this.
"I mean, you're good at this."
(Kelly laughs)
And that made all the difference to me.
I was like, "Oh really? That's cool."
And it gave me the confidence-
- It instilled confidence yeah
- You betcha.
And that's where it all began,
and thanks to Dolly and thanks to Willies
and the great people that showed up there,
even the ones that don't
remember being there,
'cause there was a lot of 'em.
- The friends in low places?
- Exactly!
(audience laughs and claps)
- I always wonder, do you keep in touch
with anybody from back then?
Like at Willies, or that
place, or in the band or-
- Oh, we're all still together.
So the guy that was the bartender
went on to be the production
manager for the whole tour.
- [Kelly] What?!
- So he runs the stadium tour.
He does everything, his
name's Brian Petree.
And then, of course, Ty.
You know, Ty's the guitar player.
We were college roommates together.
And so we're still out
here, Ty will be playing
here with us later tonight.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- Yeah it's fun.
- What was it like
playing in your dorm room?
Like, playing in your dorm
room, is that crazy, y'all?
- It was dark.
(audience laughs)
- I'm just loving that people
down the hallway were like
"Shut up!"
and you ended up being Garth Brooks.
(audience laughs)
- Exactly!
- I just love that.
Was he crazy then, was he fun?
- It was just all based on just two guys
that loved music, I think.
To this day, we knew
how we felt about music.
We just didn't know how everybody else
was gonna feel about it at the time.
- And the only difference, I think now,
is I look like this and he still
looks like he's in college.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- I look slightly different, as well.